over the weekend it's a huge story these
two guys in upstate New York these two
convicts pulled off this incredibly
inventive escape and they're gone and
the media is calling it Shawshank like
all the media is talking about how it's
this Shawshank like escape and it's such
an iconic movie I'm wondering do you get
calls are they call is the media calling
you and saying will you comment on the
big escape in upstate New York actually
those two guys called me up about a
month ago I said alternate clothing yeah
that's right no I don't I did get a few
calls and I I kind of just you know I it
for me it's a different story right and
he was innocent
right right right I'm not sure whether
these guys are guilty or innocent but
you know I apparently the jury's
convicted them yeah I don't know I I
just I I I don't think there's much of a
story there ya know it's funny because
it's like the people immediately want to
link it to a movie then realize the
movies that completely yeah okay they
escape the way Andy Dufresne escapes in
Shawshank but that's it there's no other
parallel yeah and then I heard that
people were like we gotta call tim
robbins and get his take on this what
are you talking about like okay that was
a movie this is real life right like
that
another guy it's like calling Leo
DiCaprio every time a boat sinks Leo
what do you think
there was another guy that was just
captured after being on the lam about
three months ago and someone said oh
yeah that you know someone came out to
me and said hey they caught the
Shawshank guy I'm like no that that was
an it was a book by Stephen King turned
into a movie right yeah
it is not that guy not the real guy
right we got to straighten that out with
people fiction reality did you know by
the way I found this out today just
reading all this press about this quote
Shawshank escape and then I looked up
Shawshank it is the number Shawshank
Redemption is the number one movie on
IMDB did you know that that's a that's a
bucket list yeah yeah well also Nelson
Mandela was a was a big fan of that
movie yes he was yes I met him a few
years before he died and Minh dove mine
I was staying at this hotel in South
Africa and this guy that ran the hotel
said you want to meet Nelson Mandela and
I said sure and he said well I'm having
lunch with him tomorrow and I figured
it's gonna be a big luncheon and you
know I'd get to shake his hand and we're
driving into this residential area so
where are we going he says to his house
and so it was me Nelson and one other
person at the table we had this great
lunch and talked about what happened in
South Africa the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission shawshank
redemption' he was a fan of the movie
it's interesting because he spent 27
years in prison yeah that haven't unlike
most people that love that movie he
would have a particular he'd be able to
relate in a particular way Murray yeah
yeah yeah and I mean he loved Morgan to
his friends with Morgan Freeman as well
yeah yeah that's an I mean that's the
kind of thing when you get into acting
you don't see it taking that turn no you
get your justice in this incredible
movie and then who loves it and one of
the great iconic leaders of the 20 and
21st century Nelson Mandela as a fan
that just comes out of nowhere it's
incredibly humbling and it's one of
those moments I've had a few of them
where you just pinch yourself you go
is this happening right now is right
yeah feel really honored to have been
included in his his lunch yeah by the
way do they allow I'm just curious do
they allow shawshank redemption' to be
shown in prisons visits
that's a weird it just occurred to me
like that's the kind of move it's a
great movie and prisoners get to see
movies but are they going to show on
that movie um I believe they have seen
it yes and I work in prison I do
rehabilitation with inmates in the
California correctional system and I
have to talk to the guys and they have
seen that movie yeah right and they're
like high five